perfect thank you so much for coming
this is awesome like i was saying it's
way not the smallest crowd i ever spoke
to but we have everybody on the stream
so thank you so much for joining online
today and hopefully you're going to
enjoy this presentation my name is
lauren bruno i'm a cloud advocate for
microsoft i work for azure and we're
going to take a deep dive in durable
functions so i want to warn you in
advance
if you have never heard about azure
functions this session is probably not
for you and i'm not offended if you
decide to leave right
however if you have heard we are still
going to do a quick recap just so that
we understand what durable functions
bring to the landscape that you cannot
fulfill with normal with normal
functions all right
cool so on the agenda today
we are going to start with a brief recap
like i said about normal azure functions
if you want
and then after that we'll understand why
we want to use durable functions to
solve certain scenarios
we'll check how those durable functions
even work
all right
and then we'll check also some patterns
that you can fulfill using those
functions that's going to be more or
less roughly the first half of the
presentation
but then after that we'll go into tips
and tricks
and i've been using durable functions
for about a year to solve some
problems that could be very difficult to
solve otherwise at microsoft
specifically to build some web some
parts of microsoft.com so i'm going to
show you that
and in the process of this year i made a
lot of mistakes and i'm really want you
to not make those mistakes so i'm going
to show you what i did and why it didn't
work and then the workaround
cool so azure functions
you know before i said in the you were
there right i said that my favorite
service is probably static web apps in
azure sati web apps can actually use
azure function and azure function is
probably
if not my second favorite service on
azure but it's i mean it's very close
right like first second i really love
azure functions i use them all the time
and azure functions essentially are a
part of the serverless offerings that we
have at microsoft all jokes serverless
doesn't mean there is no server it means
there is less server you have to worry
less about the server so essentially you
don't have to
worry about
deploying the server about maintaining
the server about putting an anti-virus
on it about updating the operating
system when you need to
you don't worry about all that we take
care of that for you okay that's kind of
the idea so you're going to worry only
about your code
deploying your code adding features to
your code and that's pretty much it
it's also going to scale on demand what
it means is that if you're a startup and
you have just like two users per week
you're pretty much going to pay nothing
because you're still into the free tier
of the azure function so it's very good
to experiment and to try things out but
if suddenly let's say that you have a
celebrity retweeting a tweet of yours
and then suddenly you have millions of
users no problem we are just going to
throw web virtual machines at you and
then we are going to scale
out and we are going to just handle
those requests then you're going to
start paying but it's okay because
you're also going to start selling so
you know it's only fair that at some
point
you give us back a little bit money i
have kids who needs to eat right
so
it still means that those functions are
going to be cheap to run because
when
especially in the serverless model in
the consumption model when you don't use
them you're not paying for them those
functions go to sleep and keep that in
mind because we are going to use that
later to illustrate wide variable
functions those functions go to sleep
and you don't pay for them you're going
to pay a little bit for the azure
storage basically while your code is
stored but this is really like cents per
month it's really not very much and the
runtime itself we are going to be on you
by the second so if the function runs
for uh you know one hour and 55 seconds
we are not going to believe you for two
hours we build you for that time so on
the long term they are really cheaper to
run than other comparable services
now azure functions are not the only
serverless offerings that we have on
azure we have tons of services that are
either serverless by nature or can run
in a serverless mode
for example we have logic apps logic
apps are a serverless workflow that you
can build using a building block so it's
a no code or low code scenario
we have kubernetes services aks which
can run in a serverless mode azure
cosmos db as well also has a serverless
mode so when i say serverless mode
essentially what it means is that when
you don't use it you don't pay for it
that's kind of what it means okay
we have signal r that i just
demonstrated earlier on uh which is a
service that you can also deploy in
in consumption mode in serverless mode a
static web app is also a serverless
offering etc etc
and so why do we want to use durable
functions in certain scenarios well it's
basically to answer
cases that normal functions cannot
fulfill
okay
so the issues that you have with normal
azure function in consumption mode in
serverless mode
are pretty well known these days first
of all because we don't blue when you
don't use them what it means is that
we're going to put them to sleep in
quotation marks all right
and when they wake up it takes a little
bit like just a few seconds to rehydrate
to to wake up if you want now our
engineers have worked really hard in
reducing that time and these days it's
actually pretty good but still if you
want to do some absolutely real
you know real time observation for
example of a of an iot landscape of
devices
this small rehydration time can be a
problem okay so you need to take that
into account another thing is the time
out functions after a while they give
they give up so if you have a long
running operation and by the way this
timeout in consumption mode
is between five and ten minutes
all right if you take an another plan
like we have a premium plan then it's a
little bit higher it can go up to half
an hour but if you have some operations
which take longer than that at some
point the function is going to give up
okay so you need to keep that in mind
when you architect your system also
another thing is that functions
essentially are stateless you never know
what machine they are going to run on
all right
you cannot take advantage of local files
or anything also if a function has an
error
that can be tricky to handle okay
especially if you want multiple
functions if you want to run multiple
functions
uh
in a chain for example and then one of
them has an error it's kind of hard to
notify the next one that you know maybe
it shouldn't run for example so that is
a little bit tricky to coordinate
so
what is the scenario that i used
where i first decided okay i'm going to
try durable functions now so if you go
to
docs.microsoft.even a doc.microsoft.com
event sorry this is a new part of
microsoft.com that we built to host all
of our first party events
uh ignite build etc
and essentially this is where we archive
all the videos on demand so if you go
there you're going to find for example
the videos from ignite march
now if you go to the official ignite
website the videos from march are not
there anymore okay so this is the place
where we archive them we and we plan on
continuing to archive uh videos and
essentially if you go to um
to our video website you can still see
video from 2006 from mix for example the
first conferences we had etc because
those videos really have value right so
we decided to keep them
so my boss came to me and said hey we
have about three weeks until ignite
march 2021
we want to build that thing and we want
to use the docs infrastructure so all of
our documentation at microsoft runs on
docs.microsoft.com
and the way that it's built is actually
pretty clever it is all backed backed by
some github repository
and in there you also your pages using
markdown or yaml
and then you push you commit to uh to
github and that's going to start a build
process which is going to take all that
and then build a private version
of your page
that only you with your your well
basically any microsoft employee can see
and then when you merge when you do a
pull request and you merge into a branch
which we call live
that's going to be pushed to public
okay we merge with a review typically so
that means that we have some security we
have a foreign principle where at least
two people need to see the page before
it goes live
so that allows you to build new websites
new web pages on microsoft very fast
and also it opens the door to a lot of
automation
right which is very interesting so what
i decided to do in the three weeks that
i had i built an automation system
which is using the github rest api to go
and create a new branch and commit to
that new branch
that creates a private version of the
pages
and then it allows me to check them out
quickly and then merge into live to go
public okay the last step the last merge
i still do it manually i could do it
automatically as well but i do it
manually because i like to have a last
verification before i push things to
microsoft.com right that's kind of a bad
carrier move depending what you do okay
so this is cool
but the problems that i have is that
those
changes to the to the flow of events
that i get from the api where you have
all the all the sessions
defined
that happens approximately every half an
hour because the average duration of a
session at ignite is half an hour
so
every half an hour i need to go and pull
the api which gives me a big json file
with everything that i have then i need
to build those markdown pages and then
compare with github to check if there
are some changes if there are some
changes i'm going to commit and then i'm
going to send notifications to team and
to my phone to tell me hey we have 10
new pages that or 10 pages that change
that you need to go and check all right
and the problem of course at ignite we
can have up to 300 sessions
okay so i have 300 pages that i need to
build every half an hour
okay so this is a lot of stuff and and
it could be way worse right i could have
thousands of pages etc
so this is the problem i wanted to solve
this is another view of the pages that
i'm building so for every video i have
also helper pages like landing pages and
and others
and
the ways that i decided to make this
work or the way that durable functions
work really is that you're going to have
a trigger and this trigger is going to
be an azure function
okay it could be an http function could
be a timer function in my case every
half an hour i'm running that
and this trigger function is going to
start another function which is a
special function called an orchestrator
this special function and we are going
to see all that in code later this
special function orchestrator is then
going to start an activity function the
one that actually does the work
it's going to wait until the activity
completes
then when the activity completes the
orchestrator is going to be called again
and is going to start the next activity
and then when it's completed it's going
to go back to the orchestrator and then
start the next activity
right i made this slide yesterday in the
plane it's pretty right because before i
had everything handwritten so it's
better this way
and then after that the orchestrator
starts again the last time to basically
check if everything was done in cleanup
and then return the result
okay so that's how those durable
functions work
so
i want to also mention that it's not the
only way to run workflows on azure or at
microsoft.com for that matter use power
automate or if you use logic apps this
is also some workflow coordination some
workflow orchestration
but those use a block programming
language which essentially you don't
have code there all right it's aimed at
other people not necessarily developers
so if you want to use code to
orchestrate your workflow then the
durable functions are probably a good
choice
okay
good so let's understand those patterns
and what you can solve using those
durable functions so imagine that you
have this problem you want to start a
function f1
then when f1 is finished you want to
save the state somewhere and then you
want to start another function f2 save
the state function f3 etc etc
now that is something that you can
actually solve using normal functions
you can use a normal function with a
system of qs and then the queue trigger
another function etc and then you save
the state but if you do that with a
normal function let's imagine that f2
suddenly has an error it's kind of hard
to notify f3 that something happened
right so you need to really
think very carefully about your about
your scenario
so this is very easy to use with durable
function and we are going to see a demo
in a few seconds
the other scenario which is very very
popular is what we call fan out fan in
all right so basically it means the
orchestrator is going to prepare a set
of functions think about my 300
function instances that i want to run to
create websites to create web pages and
then it's going to run them all together
and literally we are going to throw 300
300 instances of functions to you right
of course we are going to bill you
accordingly as well you will bill you
for wednesday run
and then after that the orchestrator is
going to wait until
typical scenario until all functions are
completed but since it's code you can
wait for any event you can say i want to
wait until the first is complete for
example and then i want to move on
and the cool thing is that you can
combine your
you know your function chaining with
your fan-out fan-in and of course you
can say all right first i want to do
something then i want to do 300 things
at the same time then i want to finish
with something else and that all works
one thing which is interesting to know
is that
because we want to optimize the cost
when the orchestrator starts an activity
the orchestrator is going to go to sleep
and that's important to understand some
of the tricks that i'm going to show you
later it can be very confusing when you
debug
all right what it means is that you pay
only for the function which is running
so the orchestrator goes to sleep you
don't pay for that when the activity is
finished your orchestrator is starting
starting again you're going to be built
for that time and then it starts the
other activity it goes back to sleep and
then you don't pay for the orchestrator
so you don't pay twice which is a nice
scenario but also a very confusing
scenario like we will see in the demo
okay so let's take a look
at the demo
no google i didn't talk to you
all right so let's take a look at the
demo and what i did is that i prepared
here a solution and by the way
everything i'm going to show you today
is in.net because this is a language
that i know and love i've been using.net
for more than 20 years now but
everything i tell you or most of what i
tell you also applies to a java to
javascript basically to the other
frameworks that you can use for durable
functions right so keep that in mind
so here i have this solution and by the
way you'll get the repo at the end
and let's start with the function
chaining
and what we're going to do is explore a
little bit how this works and this is
pretty much out of the box what you get
when you create a new durable function
okay so let's understand how this works
so first of all we are going to enter
here this function
which i call function chaining http
start so typically i use a naming
convention
where the orchestrator function
which is up here i give it the same name
as the class
because this is really the function that
can fulfill the whole thing
then my activity functions
usually i give them the name of the
class and a unique name because you you
don't want to have confusions right you
don't want to have two functions in the
same application with the same name
and then my http start or my whatever
start i gave it an again the name of the
class and
end http start or whatever start that is
at least it allows me to find them
easily when i look at the list of
functions okay so this is a start which
this is what's going to trigger the
whole workflow
it's an http call it's going to use a
root zero one so i'm going to say slash
api zero one okay to get
and you see that it gets here and i
durable orchestration client from the
framework
and using this orchestrator it's going
to start
here
the orchestrator function
and then it's going to return it's going
to go to sleep
now in the orchestrator function what
i'm going to do is that i'm going to
prepare a list of outputs which is a
list of string in that case could be a
list of anything really
and then i'm going to say all right i'm
going to add to this output
the result
of an activity
which is called function chaining say
hello and which uses this parameter and
again the parameter could be anything
small coverts anything that you can
serialize we'll come back to that in a
moment
so here because i have an await
it's going to wait for the result
and then only it's going to execute the
second function with a different
parameter
and that's the chaining that i was
saying before it's going to wait for the
result and then it's going to run the
third one
so this is here the activity function
it's going to just written hello and
then the name and then do some log
so let's run this and let's see what
happens
so this is starting here
the
function application i'm going to try to
put this side by side on this small
screen and here i'm going to trigger the
function from vs code using an extension
called rest client it's a pretty cool
extension which allows me to just define
the request like that
okay so now i have some break point so
if i start the function chaining
you see that i am into my http trigger
okay
i'm going to press f5 to go
and that's going to execute the
orchestrator
the orchestrator is going to call the
first activity function
here i am into the first activity
function and now if i press f5 what do
you think will happen you see i have a
breakpoint here
on line 28
that's where i should jump right that's
kind of the next step
but don't forget the orchestrator is
sleeping right now because you don't
want to pay for it so if i press f5 you
jump back at the beginning
that's super confusing the first time
you do durable function the orchestrator
runs again but this time
it's going to go to the first call
and the first call has a unique
signature it has a name here and then
the parameter and then it's not going to
run that function because i already ran
it
the result has been sterilized somewhere
i get it
and then i'm going to run the second
activity function
this time with a parameter cl
let's press f5 i go back in the
orchestrator in the beginning
i'm going to
check the result of the first one i
already ran it that's fine
check the result of the second one i
already ran it that's fine and now i'm
going to run the third one
and then i go back in the beginning
again
and then
now i have run everything and so i can
return my output okay you see the flow
so again because we put the orchestrator
to sleep to save you money
that's a little bit of a weird flow that
you need to keep in mind and there is
some serialization happening which is
another thing you need to keep in mind
okay
so to understand what happened a little
bit better
here
i have the same thing except that here i
sleep 10 seconds in each activity
function
because i want to show you something
which is pretty cool
if i go here you see i get a 202
accepted that's the response that i get
from the http start
i get that immediately
and then the http starts goes to sleep
but i also get some urls
and so let's try to run the second one
which is going to sleep a little bit
okay so here it started now it's
sleeping
and now i can go here and in my response
i can take this url which is called
status query get uri
and i'm going to open it in a web
browser and here i i get an information
about the flow and it says runtime
status running it's not done yet
okay you can interrogate that as many
times as you want
and if i go back here to my floor i have
tokyo i have seattle i'm still waiting
for london now i have london
now i can go back here and now it is
completed and it's going to give me back
the result
okay
now typically this is not how you obtain
the result typically what durable
functions do is that they go and
serialize something somewhere
to a database
to a
blob storage to github to wherever okay
that's typically what you expect
but it is interesting that you have this
api which allows you to interrogate
the other thing you can do in the api
here in the response that you get
you can send an event to your function
application
and do stuff so that's going to be added
to a queue and then you can trigger
stuff
so that can be interesting if you want
to influence the way that your
application is running
you can terminate the execution so if
you have something which is not working
fine and then you want to terminate it
you can use this url
you can also go and purge the history
now keep that in mind because later i'll
show you
that functions durable functions have a
history and that can be tricky to solve
okay so here by clicking here you can go
and purge that
and then you can also restart the
execution of a function application
okay
so that is the normal flow of a function
chaining
now let's see how the fan out fanning
works
so for fan art and fanning in the
orchestrator here i'm going to create a
new list of tasks of string and again
this string here could be anything it
just needs to be the same
as the parameter of the call activity i
think
and it needs to be the same than the
written value of the activity function
anything that is serializable can be
used
so i'm going to do this
list of task off
and here i'm going to add and notice
that this time i don't have any weight
i just call context.call activity asking
that's going to give me back a task
which is not executed yet
and i'm going to save that with the name
tokyo here then i'm going to add another
one and another one and those activities
here they don't have to be the same
activities they can have any activity
that you have as long
as the written value matches so in my
case where i'm building different
websites
different web pages i'm saying okay so i
have one activity which is going to
create the landing page the index and
then i have another activity which is
going to create all the uh all the the
particular web pages with the video
player okay
and then
when i'm ready i'm going to call task
i'm going to await task.when all
and again here i do when all but i could
do when any which is going to wait for
the first one to complete and then
continue here i'm waiting for all of
them to complete
that make sense
so to make things interesting here
i added a random so i'm saying all right
for each execution here i'm going to
wait between 5 and 10 seconds
in a random manner
so now if i run this and actually it's
already running
and i go here
and start the fan out fan in so now we
see what's going on right i have the the
three tasks are being executed but right
now they are waiting for a random time
and then i'm going to have hello to
seattle hello to tokyo hello to london
seattle tokyo london
if i run again
again they are all executing they are
waiting for random time so before i had
seattle tokyo london and now i'm going
to have
seattle london tokyo so different result
okay but it doesn't matter my
orchestrator is just going to wait for
all three to complete whatever time they
need not quite true they need to stay in
the timeout period this is still an
azure function between five and ten
minutes
but it means that i can break my problem
in small pcs
and i can run all those tasks
simultaneously
and if you need one million of those who
are going to give you one million of
those you're also going to pay for those
one millions right so you need to keep
that in mind but it is running in a very
efficient manner for the small story
when i run my 300 pages on my local
machine it takes about half an hour to
complete
because it's going to run in a
serialized my machine only has a number
of core and it cannot multi-thread as
much as the servers we have on azure but
if i run this on azure it takes about
two minutes to complete so i go from 30
minutes to two minutes which is a really
nice gain right and keep in mind that my
half an hour long task i need to run it
every half an hour so basically my
machine could not do anything else
during that time
okay so that's a nice scenario
good so let's go back to the slides
because actually we have also other
patterns that you can implement using
functions but to be honest the two that
i showed you are probably the ones
you're going to use the most i think
because this is really where it makes
sense when you want to workflow but you
can also use durable functions for
things like when you want to monitor
like to have a long running task and you
want to monitor the status you want to
check from time to time what are you
doing what are you doing etc so you can
absolutely have your function serialize
some state have another function get
that state and return that to the caller
and see what's going on
another scenario we have is basically
monitoring
stuff right so you have something in the
field which is happening you want to get
this information build a dashboard
that's a great scenario for a durable
function
when you have a human interaction this
is an interesting one because you don't
know how long the human is going to take
to answer
and you don't want to pay for the time
that you're waiting so that's a good
scenario for a for an orchestrator like
that as well
when you have some aggregation of state
right you're you're basically gathering
a whole lot of things and if you go to
the page at the end i'll give you the
link to the documentation page we are
detailing all those patterns a little
bit there in detail so that you
understand but essentially what i want
to say durable functions are great when
you have a long-running task that you
want to break in smaller portions
or when you have a lot of things that
you want to execute in parallel
or every time you want to monitor
something and you don't exactly know
when the events are going to arrive this
is how the scenarios in which variable
functions make a lot of sense
so let's go into
the tips and tricks
and talk a little bit about those
mistakes i made and how hopefully you're
not going to do the same
so we are going to talk about a few
things the first thing is
non-deterministic execution
essentially each function is running
i'm going to say trendy buzzword as a
microservice
right it is completely isolated from the
others
and it needs to run this way which means
that there are a few things that you
shouldn't do
another thing you keep you have to keep
in mind which is important to understand
what's going on here is that again the
orchestrator goes to sleep but because
of the way that the the azure function
applications are architected when it
wakes up again there is absolutely zero
guarantee that is going to be on the
same machine
in fact it could be in the totally
different building
it could even potentially be depending
on how you architect you're seeing in a
different country
okay you don't know so you can't rely on
stuff which is local
okay
then the other thing is what happens
when you have errors in your application
and also how do you handle the history
and that is really something that can be
super super confusing when you debug
and i don't know if it's going to happen
today it's kind of random the way that
it happens but an orchestrator hates
when a task is not complete
it wants to finish it
and it's going to remember because when
you break the execution of an activity
function and that's typically what you
do when you debug right you debug press
f you know f5 f5 f10 f10 then suddenly
you're like oh wait i did uh oopsie here
i need to to fix it you stop
then you go and then you start the game
what is your orchestrator going to be to
do it's going to go and check the queues
you can just say oh you didn't finish
before
let's run again right where you were and
this is like extremely confusing when
you debug i'm going to show you how you
can clear that up
another thing is serialization
so this is really a keyword in azure
functions and when you use javascript
it's kind of easier because you know
javascript json is kind of
you know
native to to javascript if you want but
if you use any other language which is
using a json serializer then there are
some things that you need to you know
keep in mind and that can be tricky and
so the serialization is what happens
every time that the function goes to
sleep it's going to serialize its state
in azure storage i'm going to show you
that in a second and then when the
function starts it's going to get its
state from the same azure storage and
this is all in json format
another another thing you shouldn't do
is wait in the orchestrator but you're
going to tell me oh but you just waited
on the execution of the function in the
orchestrator yes but that function was
special that task was created by the
orchestrator context that's okay but if
you await something else like an http
client your application is going to
crash i'm going to show you how you can
work around that
and then debugging because it can be
very difficult to debug who has ever
debugged multi-threaded applications
raise your hand
yeah did you like it it's really fun now
yeah yeah that's exactly what happens
essentially you have everything
happening at the same time and then
keeping track is really tricky so i'm
going to show you a small trick i use to
make things a little bit easier when i
debug
all right so let's go back to the demo
we have half an hour for that more or
less it's absolutely
perfect so let's go back to our
application here
and
the first thing i want to show you is a
non-deterministic thing
so here i have my orchestrator
and my orchestrator is going to get an
environment variable name username
that's the use that's my username on
this windows machine
and then i'm going to use that to call
my activity function
okay
so if i run this
here
i'm going to get here
the variable my username is album that's
good that's my layers
then i'm going to call
the
the activity function
when the activity function is complete
i'm going to go back into the
orchestrator in the beginning
then i'm going to get the environment
variable again
and here because i'm running this on my
local machine the username is the same
but if you run this on azure there is
absolutely zero guarantee that is going
to be the same username could be
anything really
okay if you're getting things which are
time dependent
that's going to be a different value and
then what's going to happen if you try
to call the activity i think with a
different value well it's going to start
a new activity because it's going to say
oh that's a totally different state
right so you don't want to do that
in fact
in some scenarios you're going to get a
warning in the output telling you you
shouldn't do that
but let's face it who reads those
another thing you don't want to do is
this and
it may sound logical after everything i
told you but this is actually a line
taken from a code review that i gave to
someone you know a few weeks ago
in a function you don't file dot append
alt text or you don't file dot write all
or you don't do anything with local
files because you don't know the machine
is going to run on
this machine as soon as the function is
done it's going to be discarded and we
are going to use it for something else
right don't save stuff locally what you
want to do is save stuff in a well-known
place which is remote could be a
database could be whatever
so if i run this i'm going to have some
actually it's going to run but i'm going
to have some issue i'm going to stop it
because it might help me to illustrate
another point i want to make
now i'm going to restart
okay and then i'm going to show you the
deterministic code
so the deterministic code here this is a
way that you can actually code
these kind of things in a safe way
is that the first thing you're going to
be
to do in the uh in the starter all right
in the in the trigger you're going to
get the information that you want to get
and here it's safe to do
environment.environment variable i kind
of question the usage of username on
azure but you know if you want you can
do that then you're going to save that
into a class which i'm going to give to
my orchestrator as a parameter
that's going to be serialized
and then the orchestrator every time
that the orchestrator starts
it's going to obtain this value from the
context
the serialization but the value is
always going to be the same because it
has been obtained only once okay so that
makes sense the other thing here
is that when you save stuff you should
save to an online storage somewhere
could be a database could be an azure
table it could be a blob storage it
could be github it could be whatever you
want but don't save things locally on
your machine
okay
good so that's the deterministic example
that the first example
now let's move on to this fun thing the
error case so here i have a case for
example where
you see i'm throwing an exception here
which essentially means i'm going to i'm
not going to finish my task i'm going to
interrupt the task before it goes on
right
so let's go and run this
here we go
so now i jump into the orchestrator okay
the first time it's calling with tokyo i
say the exception should be thrown only
if it's seattle
so the first time it's going to run fine
now it comes back i'm going to go to the
second time and now i'm going to have
this exception which is thrown
so here typically what i do is that i i
say okay i'm going to stop the execution
and solve the problem when i debug
but then when i restart like i said it's
very possible that my orchestrator is
going to say hey you had something going
on let's restart here which means that
essentially even though i don't call the
http start it's still going to trigger
anyway
okay so the way that it works
is because when you create a new durable
function application
you need to provide a storage account
and that's true for any function
application really because we need some
place to store the code at the very
least but here in addition we are going
to store some cues
and those queues here
they have a specific name they are
called in that case test hub name it
could be another name dash control dash
and then you see that you have a number
of those
those cues are what the runtime is using
to coordinate the orchestration
okay so again it's a stateless thing the
orchestrator when it starts it gets some
state from the runtime when it goes back
to sleep it saves stuff it says hey i'm
here in the execution
and then it goes to sleep and then it
forgets right and then it is rehydrated
and then it needs to start again getting
the state that's the first thing that we
create
the other thing is that here in the
container so in the blob service
we also get here those two which are
applies and liz's
okay that's where the state is stored
that's where the json objects are being
stored
all right
so
when you run your code
it's going to go there it's going to
take it and say oh now i'm going to jump
back and then i'm going to execute again
and this is quite confusing so i'm going
to show you a quick trick
if you go into your host.json
and now depending on what
what framework you implement your
function with it's going to be a
different place but this is always a
place where you can configure your
application all right here i can
actually add a configuration
which is going to say all right the name
of the hub
should be
and here you see i'm using percent which
means it should be an environment
variable that you're going to get from
the environment
okay so that means that this host.json
is going to be deployed to azure that
you cannot change it when it's deployed
but what i can change is the
configuration
and so in the configuration i can say
all right the generate document task hub
and i'm going to give it a name
and here you see i have zero zero three
let's go back to zero zero one
and essentially when i run when i debug
my code but don't do that in production
right when i debug my code
sometimes when i see oh i need to
interrupt a long running operation in
the middle i'm going to go and then i'm
going to change that name like this i
know that i have a fresh slate i restart
fresh
another way which is actually
supposed to be a cleaner way
is to use this purge history delete uri
that you get when you execute
but i can guarantee you that you're not
going to save those
you're going to forget
and then when you actually need it it's
too late
and also i had some cases where this uri
actually didn't work so it i clicked and
then nothing happens you know it's
tricky right
so the other way is a safe way where you
can go and you can say all right so now
i'm going to use another hub name
so now if i run this
and go and execute one of the function
execution
all right so i'm just going to wait that
it starts
okay it's funny because when i when i
actually rehearsed that presentation it
kept jumping in the middle of an
interrupted task and i wanted to show
you that and now it doesn't so of course
that's the demo effect but believe me it
will happen right when you debug so now
i started the application again i'm
going to execute one of the functions
let's execute one which is the function
chaining because it's a safe one to run
okay
here it has run and now if i go back
to my
container storage i see that now i have
a new one which is called test generate
documents task hub zero zero one dash
and then apple's and lizzie's and if i
go in the queue
i see that i have this one
if now i have the problem again that
it's jumping left and right and i don't
understand what's happening
no problem i can go back
to my visual studio i can say in the
configuration and by the way you can do
that in the staging slot as well don't
do that in production really right
because then you're going to lose state
but if you are in the in the testing
slot you can also do that here i mean
local settings.json on azure it would be
in the configuration of the function
application
i can change the name i can run again
okay
and when it runs again if i go back here
and refresh
now i should see that i have zero zero
two
and now at this point i can safely say
oh i can clean up i'm going to remove
everything which is 0 0 1.
okay be careful when you delete stuff
because if you delete stuff but you
didn't change the name then your
function is going to fail and you can
search for a long time what happened now
okay so this can be tricky but
essentially now i say all right so my
cues and my container the ones that are
zero zero one i'm not using them anymore
i can clean up and again please don't do
that in production that can be really
tricky so when you when you deploy to
production and you have a hub name
please stick to that hub name it's very
easy to break an application function uh
function application sorry using this
kind of things where you're going to
delete stuff that you shouldn't all
right so be careful
okay
so hopefully that illustrates a little
bit better how those functions work
so let's go and see the serialization
thing so serialization again what i'm
showing you here in javascript might not
happen because json is kind of native to
javascript so it's a little bit easier
if you java and use the serializer then
most probably you're going to have this
kind of issue so i'm going to put a
breakpoint here
so what i'm doing is that instead of
passing the name directly i'm passing a
class
which has a property called name and
this is typically what you do you pass a
you know a set of information to your
activity function
and then after that inside the activity
function
i'm going to
i'm going to shout at the user in
uppercase so i'm going to call info.name
the two upper
okay
so let's try and run this
in that case is also one case that i had
to scratch my head a little bit
and when the function is ready
here the function is ready i'm going to
call here serialization
okay so i jump into my code i have my
info class i can go and inspect the name
property it's tokyo
i'm going to execute i jump into my
activity function and what happens oh no
i have a null reference exception
because my name is null
well if you have ever done anything with
serialization.net you probably know what
happened
what happened here is that
my
setter is internal
and you cannot do that if you serialize
json in javas.net everything needs to be
public
internal means that the seller can be
called by classes which are inside the
same assembly
the serializer is not in the same
assembly so what it's going to do it's
going to serialize properly because the
getter is public but then when it writes
back to the object the seller being
internal it's not going to find it it's
going to give up without any warning by
the way
and then it's just not going to set it i
can tell you i scratch my head a little
bit on that one
okay so of course
obviously the
fix is to do that public
but
if here i decide hey i'm going to be a
very efficient programmer and i want to
add a new property
and this property doesn't exist but it's
fine because i'm going to get some
refactoring tool and i'm going to
generate this property
awesome but when visual studio generates
property
it generates then as internal by default
and so you can really get beaten by that
especially when you're in the zone right
and you're coding and you're refactoring
and you're adding your stuff and then
you forget to go and change it to public
and that's only nothing works so that is
the thing to be careful about
so it's one of the serialization gotchas
now the other one is a little bit
clearer
and this is a scenario that i do all the
time
so i'm running this show called learn
live on microsoft learn tv okay it's a
thing i started and because i'm running
and my assignment was i need to scale
things up i was like oh cool scale up
means durable function i'm going to
generate tons of stuff using automation
and durable functions
so i have a learn live series
and this learn live series has a list of
learn life modules which you are doing
of episodes if you want
and typically when i do that because
those learn live modules they are going
to create some documents like some
markdown some emails some meeting
requests some stuff
it's really easier if i have a link
a reference to the parent to the series
because i'm going to want to get some
information from the series now in
dotnet this is no problem at all because
it's all by reference
okay it doesn't cost me anything it just
cost me a reference pointer essentially
but when you try
to run this
serialization the serializer is not
going to be very happy because i have a
learn module who has a link to a parent
who has a link to all the learn modules
who have a link to a parent who have a
link to all their own modules who have a
link to the parent and
you know i'm not going to bore you and
continue until the end but essentially
you see the problem right so if i go and
run here the serialization recursion
okay now i am inside my thing so i'm
going to
uh where is f10 here i'm going to
instantiate my series and then i'm going
to call that and
oops it's not jumping anywhere and in
fact i have a whole lot of red
and the red is newtons of the json so
i'm using
basically the durable functions are
using json.net in the background
and then it says where is it now
self-referencing loop detected for
property parent with type blah blah blah
so essentially it says oh there is a
recursion happening i cannot do that
because that's going to generate an
endlessly big
json file so you cannot do that
so instead
what you're going to do
is go inside your learn live module here
i'm going to say the parent i'm going to
mark it as
jason ignore i'm going to say don't
serialize that
okay
which means that in my
um
oops sorry
let's go back in my thing here in the
activity function
before i do work i'm going to have to
say oh for each module in the series
module the parent equal series here
there is no serialization within the
function until unless you write it
yourself so that is safe to do but you
need to keep that in mind because
otherwise you're not going to be able to
serialize your objects okay so those are
kind of the smaller chars which are
caused by the fact that because the
function go to sleep there is a
serialization
system happening
in the azure storage and then when it's
rehydrated it needs to run and that's
going to be an issue unless you do these
kind of tricks
okay so
what else do we have a weight in
orchestrator now this one is a good one
so the orchestrator is a little bit of a
special type of function it's going to
orchestrate a bunch of things but it
needs to do it in a specific manner
so here i have an orchestrator
where i happily create an http client
and i'm going to call an api
and then i'm going to use the result to
run an activity function
okay
now the problem here is that if i run
this
if i run this it's actually going to
work but it's going to protest a lot and
this is really not something you want to
do okay so my function hey yay see what
happened i didn't press anything
okay straighter remember hey you didn't
finish
then it jumped back that's what i wanted
to demonstrate i should probably go and
clean that state
okay
sorry totally not linked to the demo
that i wanted to show you but this is
what i was hoping would happen at some
point because again this is like super
confusing and by the way this is causing
an exception remember so that is a
problem right so at some point i would
probably have to go back oh and you see
now it's jumping here again i didn't
touch anything right it's just the
orchestrator saying hey you didn't
finish this you didn't finish that that
doesn't work oh no okay i just press f5
in that case
because it should run okay
let's go back to the demo forget
everything that you just saw in the past
15 seconds we go back to the problem
which is i'm going to await in my
orchestrator okay
so
let's go here
now i'm inside my orchestrator
i'm going to go and call this api using
the client using the http client that
actually works fine
but
here i'm okay
but when i try the next away which is
this time oh wait context
then all hell will break loose and
essentially what it says here it says
multi-threaded execution was detected
this can happen if the orchestrator
function code awaits on a task that was
not created by a durable orchestrating
orchestration context method
that's a long error message but let's
give credit to the guys who wrote that
it's actually very descriptive you know
what happened you cannot wait on
something else in the context tasks okay
so instead what do you want to do
well what you want to do is here
the first in my orchestrator on the
first run i'm going to call another
activity
and in this other activity called call
get random names that's where i'm going
to call my http client and wait for the
result that's fine i can wait on
anything i want in the activity
functions
okay
when it returns
i'm going to run the orchestrator again
this time i'm going to have a safe
call to the storage to get the
serialized value and then i can pass
that to my activity function
the other advantage of doing things this
way
is that
this await here is going to be executed
only once
the first time that the activity
function is called
okay and then the next time that the
orchestrator arrives at this line it's
going to get some serialized state from
the storage and then the await is not
going to be called again so it's also an
optimization
okay so it makes sense to do things this
way and plus you're not going to crash
your application with a lot of red which
is not my favorite color in a console
application
all right
good
last
example i want to show you
now this one is really fun when you try
to run stuff so i noticed my breakpoints
are messed up so i'm going to put them
back
so here what i'm going to do
i'm going to create
10 tasks
notice that there is no weight here so
i'm going to just create those tasks and
then i'm going to run them all in
parallel
and then i'm going to try to understand
what happens
well you know the two hardest things in
programming are multi-threaded execution
and naming stuff
right so here we are in the first
scenario which is really hard
okay so let's uh
trigger that so i'm going to go into the
debugging
all right
now i have created my 10 tasks notice
that those tasks
are in state waiting for activation all
right they are not executed yet they are
waiting it's a little bit small but this
is what it says here and now if i run f5
now i jump into my activity function
very cool i press f5 again oh no i'm in
the same location but for another
function
i press f5 again and oh no i'm in the
same place but in another function and
so if i really want to debug pressing f5
at some point i'm going to jump in the
end oh now i'm here but is it the first
function that was executed or is it the
third one well i have no clue basically
right
maybe you can find out according to the
name but in that case the name is null
that's not going to help me a lot
and essentially it's really hard to
debug these kind of things
so what i recommend
when you debug when you create your
stuff try to run one at a time or else
you're going to lose your sanity so
essentially what i do is that here i
would put a nice commands
and then i would probably deploy to
production and forget to remove it so
don't do that either that's why we have
two ice cone you know two eyes oh sorry
four eyes two two people four eyes uh
concept where basically don't forget to
remove that because that's going to mess
everything up but at least if i run this
code now it's going to run just one call
of my activity function and then it
allows me to really understand what's
going on when i'm happy then i go back
and then i remove that
before i deploy to production okay so be
careful with these kind of things but
really that can be really tricky to
develop and to debug
all right so that's pretty much what i
wanted to show you today
so
we talked about functions and
wow
we did a brief recapitulation about
azure function we understand we
understood
where do functions come from but also
some of the limitations that they have
and then we understood why do we want to
use durable functions to overcome those
limitations we understood how those
durable functions work by the way i
didn't mention that but it's actually
pretty clever how it's done it's an
extension component that you add to your
function application so initially when
they were first released
your function applications didn't have
the durable function part but you could
add it now it's pretty much there from
the start when you create a new function
application in visual studio it's going
to be already configured to run your
able function so it's way easier
then we saw those patterns all right the
function chaining the fan out fanning
those two patterns that you're going to
use a lot but you can also monitor
things or wait on things using this and
then we saw those tips and tricks errors
i made and that i hope you never make
if you want to learn more about azure
function this is a place where you can
go it's our learn
space on microsoft you don't need an
azure account to go there it doesn't
cost you anything we give you some
sandbox where you can actually deploy
your azure function it's going to last
for two hours and then after that we
discard everything so it's a good place
don't try to go and use that for bitcoin
mining we actually detect that and we
prevent that from happening
just to be clear but if you want to
learn this is really a great place to go
so you can absolutely go and use that
and finally this is uh what you need so
this is where you get the slides and all
the resource codes so this is really the
url that you want the one saying durable
functions pattern at the at the bottom
there this is where you can go and see
all those other patterns the monitor one
the human interaction one etc etc
and finally this is me so if you want to
come and talk to me say hi please do so
i'm going to be here the whole day i'm
going to flying back home tomorrow
and hopefully this was useful for you my
name is omino i'm a cloud advocate for
microsoft thank you so much for your
attention and have a great day
so i guess i did finish a little bit
early so if you have a question i can
take it and i'm going to repeat it for
the people i just said stories that i
didn't have question but you know i
sometimes i'm like this any questions
yes
what's the difference between a
function that runs for two
no
i mean yes sorry sorry
basically we bill you by the execution
time
okay and by the second so if you run a
function for two seconds it's going to
be cheaper to run than if you if they
run for two minutes but however we do
have in the oh by the way the question
for my online audience was what is the
difference between those functions if
they run for two seconds or two minutes
is there a difference well yeah
obviously the two minute one is going to
cost more we view you by the second
um however um there is also a generous
free tier and there is there are good
chances that a lot of what you do
especially during the development part
but also during the startup phase of
your application when you don't have so
many users it's going to fall into that
free tier so you're not going to pay we
start billing i can't remember exactly
but there is a there is a number of
execution where we start billing
if you want to have more information
about that we have the uh the keyword is
azure pricing calculator where you can
go but essentially there is no
difference in the way that those are
handled the differences that the ones
that last longer are going to cost more
that's really what it is plus we build
you a little bit for the storage so if
you use storage uh to store the state
like in that case or to store just the
code of your function then it's going to
cost you a little bit this is cents per
month so it's not much okay
cool i guess we have one more question
maybe
well everything was clear so time for
coffee after two sessions in a row thank
you so much for coming and hopefully it
was useful thank you